ok I want to
speak
tempe
ok now I multiplicity Canby
interprets
Andy of The Hobbit the multiplicity
of the inveriaform
bye positive
you don't stop ok
what is the main example is
the orbit is the determinant
Seas of complexity of the result of the
problem  as explicit bridge of you I
computing her the dimension of the
atmosphere
of conclusion
one
news
result vanishing for this mentions
is the world
OK
on 16
ok columnist coefficient it
determine by the given of three
partition laxat of the same integer and
so
representation of of symmetric
alpha of
society of indépatisfense decomposition
the representation
giving the Chronicles
first to the
for mathematical bridge of you note
complex
coefficient generalize this one Enzo the
question house
description of the problem here can be
extended to this setting
the question
Windows
definition
of Candice
of condiment
c'  is exactly simulant but for more
complicated
of beta bar ismolers the some of sun
parts
gammaba
7 of
blackboard we know one l 7
boxes androse index by high
all satisfied we are
just you take
Oney quality
ment is not to same Asus
rectangular partition
in this work
and eyes
is condition
no no
conditions the points
t
giving an example
ok
yes yes
OK yes
yes
exactly
S
step to use
ok
vanishing
the correspondig vanishing
space and not to the determinant
ok is located
fundamental is the true obstruction the
second is just relative
algorithm
all simple taxes